and i started playing basketball and you
know my father just kept pushing me
pushing me pushing me
and then you know that this was around
83 84 where the no pass no play rule
came out so i tried to test my father's
theory one time and didn't pass and he
wouldn't let me play that devastated me
so i really started focusing on
academics then wasn't the smartest guy
but you know just enough to comprehend
and you know get me back and and from
then on you know my father pulled me to
the side one day i said if you listen to
me i can make you the best big man ever
so i started listening to him and he
would he would tell he would say that
yes he was so he was big on affirmations
constantly facing you yes and so when he
says if you listen to me what is he
saying listen to what he said he said if
you listen to me all your dreams will
come true and i'll make you the best big
man ever and i had to listen to him
anyway because it was a jerk he was a
drill sergeant and
he had a twin brother named belt
his twin brother named belt so i had to
listen to him
or else